egy nőnek a lelke a plusz 3 kg-tól vagy
plusz 5 kg-tól is össze tud ripityára
törni és az öt az még nem egészségtelen
az önmagához vagy a normális normális
testsúlyához a megszokott testúlyá
testsújához képest az 5 kg az még nem
lesz egészségtelen tehát hogy én nem
szeretném hogy azzal az üzenettel menjen
el egy nő most erről a a a a podcastet
meghallgatva hogy ő 5 vagy 10 kgóval
több mint amennyi kellene
legyen nem tudom kihez képest és akkor ő
csúnya és akkor ő csúnya igen viszont a
nők nem tudják hogy hány kilósak kéne
legyenek akár önmagukhoz képest sem van
egy testtömegindex ami jobb hián az
behatárol val így van ami behatárol
valahova de nem ezt fogja meghatározni
hogy ő egészséges